she looks like the shittiest Mortal
Kombat character you get finished Alenia
get your life together
[Applause]
security for Korean Zombie right he
looks like yeah he looks like Gangnam
out of style in that little [__] egg
roll
you mean don't stop when a man when the
world took advantage of a mentally
handicapped it made him dance on YouTube
way he was handy girl oh yeah yeah that
ain't natural Asian bro natural aging
comes more no it's the most-watched
music video in history I guess
7 billion views yeah all China watch so
automatically number 1 damn Gangnam
style yeah it was sad man at one part of
it no he's not the handicapped one there
he is right there and here you go right
here that's him yeah that's him no
Williams dancing Oh William Williams
Asia
okay all right wait what [__]
you must have a lot of hooks you must
have a lot of hidden cartilage dude it's
very flexible dance
look how malleable he is look at his
knees it is yeah oh my he's so nimble
yeah he told me that his parents named
him did you know this is his parents
named him rad Williams ra.d
and he changed it yeah yeah way cooler
that's cool
what was rad I think he just thought it
was insane you know like by like you
know people were trying always gonna do
biking and stunts and [__] no no baby
yeah they want to be in jackass right
away he was like seven yeah he comes out
of hot sauce in your eyes if you're a
rad eg Stone taxman do jump off this
cliff and I'm six yeah everything's a
cliff that's a kid you know you're such
a good job that is a kid joke it wasn't
easy chip that's a kid job okay
I took it the wrong way cuz he still has
six hiding him he's got the height of a
city he's still got a six just the
spirit of a 7-footer though you feel me
oh yeah that's it here he stands tall oh
crack him open dude he's off the charts
man mm-hmm Cadbury egg real sweet yeah
he's in the 2000 percentile you crack
him open Rollie cream cream boy when you
hide that little dessert cuff you just
hide I downed it yeah yeah the second
time I cheat on my diet today it's the
Lord's it's the thick Lord's work I've
been good I've been good
I rode my mountain bike seven miles this
morning and I've been on my diet and
then I got to the copy shop and I just I
can't turn down pancakes they said you
want some free pancakes I'm free this is
the thick Lord upstairs shining down on
the repay and I get here and Nick has
[__] banana pudding oh yeah that [__]
is fantastic this is beautiful huh and
where'd you come across this uh dessert
Nick she's bored as [__] bacon do a lot
of women better something betters
tighten up those old school skills
suddenly we're on the same right here
start doing the laundry around the crib
Hill with something you know a lot of
[__] ladies just stranded do you see
a lot of Instagram I was trapped in
their apartment laundry everywhere sad
no flights nobody gonna Tulum no not on
that God anymore we back streets out
welcome to real life welcome got them
skills anymore yeah welcome to real life
a little Dorothy okay haven't had that
quarantine dick seven weeks yeah I
haven't had that all senior citizen
pecker in a while they having to pay
their own bills you get real if T bottom
women really to reading the directions
on a box oatmeal right now
figure out how to figure out them
Totino's pizza rolls don't microwave my
[__] either [__] he is too soggy yeah
dang you like fully baked huh that's how
you gotta bake them man they're already
cheap you know you put them the
microwave those things get real gushy
yeah like gushers but pizza filled yeah
I don't trust anybody that bites in them
right up the oven either some psychopath
dude who can eat those that hot it's
lava in your [__] mouth yeah you're
just like oh yeah I want to take it I
want to take a fricking ride with the
devil you buy the road and it just
sprays it's like the big bang that
started the entire universe in the back
here dude when that pizza when that
Totino's bust in your mouth that lava
but tikkun dude third degree burns on
the roof of your mouth dude nothing work
brother ain't nothing quarters well my
buddy got third-degree burns on the hip
side of his eyes from having its Ito's
or old bro when they came out with sauce
only no pepper gosh sure dude dude some
of it came out the back of it you don't
have a throat or anything anymore man
it's bizarre I repeat the other night
the dude came to the house drop the
piece off rang the door one [__] ran
off dude
he didn't want nothing he's so scared of
[__] that Corona Ronin that Rona
yeah what's going on in the urban
community of Chappelle are you here are
you guys hearing a lot about the core
the coronavirus what's happening with it
I mean her black people is scared of it
as white people and others I think we
seem to be good I don't know I mean dude
this isn't a racist thing I was in
Inglewood the other day I was in
Inglewood yeah I was in England doing
the what chillin what your car got
stalled out over there no a friend
Roscoe Roscoe's chicken the line was
Raptor Amin they don't get [__] yeah
no you [__] no mass nothing no damn
living no man they're living I saw one
black lady with a football helmet on him
like that
is it Raiders was it the Raiders I
wasn't it was a high school team okay
look it was at Long Beach Poly lunch all
hi I don't know what it was man I said
that [__] he stopped it but I mean
actually if I was a quarter virus I
would not [__] with that Lake I wouldn't
at all man
Corona scared of black people I could
see that here so mm-hmm
black people kids yep I could see that
mm-hmm
I'm just glad to be here man Amen bro
I'm glad to see you guys man don't touch
me dude but we can't but we can
yeah yeah touch me without gloves on man
can I see that Gangnam style video I
know yeah and uno G hey look it's a
scarf with the mask scars for later you
look like you've up to Robin noodle Bank
what is that is that a panty what is it
is that a real man it's a real mask it's
disposable so I usually but one day just
one day and that's gotta go are you
serious yeah you look like an Ikea ninja
[Laughter]
and why is that why is it why you why
you can't use it more often exposed to
the elements once it goes out I can't
use it again what elements you mean
airborne stuff viruses germs
now [__] all that Rona
dude I was on the trails this morning on
mountain biker now it's all I do
I was on the trails I saw big old ass
tell him Chappelle I saw big big cat
prints in the mud
really I was so scared I took my
headphones out did you really I don't
have knives nothing what am I gonna do
you got to get a piece man gotta get
handy with the steel brother piece on
your bike nobody's gonna lose gonna say
oh that guy shouldn't have a gun oh
you're right you're right I got to do
something
I can't kill that thing in my hand oh
it's scary I went for a run one time and
the woods somewhere
and I remember at one point he started
getting dark I ran too far and had to go
back you know and I got to the finish
line and I was like oh [__] dude the
finish on his way deep in the woods I
gotta go back so and I started getting
real dark as I got closer to my car and
it was like just hello woods Brian I was
like dude this is I'm if I'm a cat
bright act me right yeah that's how
cold-case file starts yeah every cold
case starts that way yeah light jog yeah
it you see a white lady why didn't get
your sweatshirt and the kiosk at the
mall somebody made this who made this
knit let me look that up he was he was a
fan he was actually in here because he
was doing something designer man did did
he spray-paint it does he have
Tourette's he's actually a really hot
street designer I guess he was here with
some clothing company actually Teddy
fresh the h3 people they have a
streetwear brand and they were trying to
do a collab and he walked past he saw
Theo's office let's get was like he had
he made it cool you don't know who he is
I will find it in I'll just play about
Toretto's trying to make it be sting
when I arrived it's kind of nice the
inside feels soft man yeah get in there
bro okay
the standard dude I remember being all
high one night kind of hit on some girl
and I didn't I was too [__] up to talk
and so I she had on like a sweatshirt
number were taking my [__] hands and
like putting them up or sweatshirts up
they were in your head you're just
trying to see the quality of the
sweatshirt no no I'm trying to like
touch this lady but a lot of her body
was in the sweat okay and which I'm
thinking oh how can I talk to that you
know I can't talk yeah so it just be
like oh that's a soul brother dude it's
right but we can't we still we talked
for a little while but I have to so it
worked did you start laughing huh she
wasn't wearing a football helmet in
r.i.p Malcolm X as well real so there's
a good documentary on Netflix on that
very shady dude
I remember I was hitting on a girl I my
crush setnet like crush sat next to me
in fourth grade earth science I'll never
forget this right and I was like oh is
the start of a probably call her crush
because anything that big [__] sat on
Joy's Joy's were overalls and she had
blonde hair
her name was something Lee you know like
like three names something like Kathie
Lee something I remember it was the
middle was Lee
really I was so excited she sitting next
to me and I was finally gonna talk to
her but I felt like this this raisin
sized booger in my nose I'm like oh boy
I'm just gonna and I was like you know
where I remember watching a movie class
it was dark and crazed guy I was knuckle
deep in my nose and then I felt this I
felt this raisin right and then I was
like where the [__] did it go oh my god
whatever oh I hate and I'm like what's
up girls for this [__] is crazy she goes
oh my god oh my Jayant burger right you
know what
and I felt and this thing was just yeah
okay game set match shoes I'll see ya
dude you had that [__] that uh boogie
what's that basketball players name
boogie woogie calling yeah that boogie
cousin's brother market brim game set
match
oh yeah it's hard to hit on a woman you
know and so I made a mistake during
starvation people eat their boogers a
lot I feel sick is it this is the
designer Nick this is yum right there
your boy right there real one on her tag
that sounds real Street where there bro
yeah so shout-out real 100 tech who drop
this off probably almost a year ago
maybe oh nine months ago but I thought
this was recent maybe it wasn't a year
ago we've only been here since July 1st
so maybe December yeah couldn't even
have been a year it's been a hot second
though a year ago dear years years ago
oh he's got that Tiger king hit or two
he's got up there and we're on that but
that third one on the bottom right that
kind of dark blue there's a lot going on
huh yeah oh that's pretty dopey [__]
sigh I'd Rock to show that you heard him
real one hunter tech
oh I hate that thing dude bro you know
what I'm thinking about man I'm thinking
about getting maybe uh one of those um
one of those things they sound perverted
but they're good panini bruh yeah you
free what are you ordering I just
ordered lunch for the entire studio did
you really I did post minutes can drop
it off
Oh 48 minutes less than an hour you
freaks yeah well that's the thing about
post minds they say you could get
anything in less than an hour you can
get dude you could get a guy you could
have them say look I want a sandwich and
they bring you something you bring you a
sandwich bring you a piece of cutter pie
dude sometimes my post mates yeah
they're dropping off food why stay thick
but they're also kind of my therapist
really he comes all right Stockton and
who is he it's different people
sometimes a gal sometimes too dude oh
yeah
have you had Vlad come dude vlogs the
bad Russian you don't even talk back but
I just talked his ear off bro one guy I
ordered the burger I ordered it was
right too rare he freaking lit the bag
on fire on my doorstep I was like oh
yeah hell yeah just download post Bates
on iOS or Android if you use Android
yeah what every Android is yeah whatever
that is find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within an
hour post mates is giving you guys $100
a free delivery credit for your first
seven days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use the code Kay
80s 2020 they got everything man they
got everything you want a chip you want
to cut a cake you know what I'm saying
you want a little serving a pudding bra
you're gonna choke on a churro they got
that yeah if you would get that churro
extra well done bra you know what I'm
saying extra crispy and then you can
probably order a coffin on there too you
can finish up the whole juicy if your
mom can deep throat a dry churro right
now bro I don't know if it's about that
but it can be man it's whatever you want
and for a limited time
postmates give an hour listener $100 bra
yep
[Music]
$100 god that's crazy free delivery
credit with no minimum yes first seven
days god anything you need
anytime you need it post me to you're
free first seven days to start your free
delivery
download the
and use code k 80s to zero to zero
that's code cats 20 20 per 100 100 large
[Music]
free delivery credit wit no minimum
purchase but
that's right that's cats 2020 for $100 a
free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase anything you need anytime you
need it oh look man what I'm trying to
tell you God look I feel you bro you've
been using the old-fashioned ways of
mailing stuff yeah my stuff's not
getting there man you got any other
freaking ideas yeah man look i'ma tell
you something a lot of some people do
all type of stuff you want to mail
something you take it over there to the
mail station and they got your girl back
there Shawn Driss you know what I'm
sayin yeah she gots 95 different
haircuts going on and don't give a [__]
if she got that attitude oh damn all
goddamn day
I want to ship a dick pic to your mom
bro yeah and I'm gonna use ship station
it helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and keep your customers
happy
a man bro if you're blind if you're not
blind it doesn't even matter
praise Christ bro ship station no matter
where you're selling Amazon Etsy your
own website ship station brings all your
orders into one simple we're right here
baby
it sounds good it does sound good man
making it makes it really easy to manage
your order and your shipping from any
device even your even your cell phone if
you have to ship stuff quit doing it the
old-fashioned way man
dude no wonder ship station number one
choice of online sellers and right now
King this thing listeners can try ship
station felt free for 60 days when you
use the offer code Kay 80s ship station
dot-com
yep they even offer big discount on ship
and cost what clicking the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in K 80s
that ship station calm then enter the
code cats yep click on the microphone at
the top of the home page click and type
in K a TS that ships a side them and in
her code ki Tia
ship station calm make ship happen dude
Tiger King is released on a bonus
episode I heard dude I got a friend who
knows the the girl the nanny that badass
nanny mm-hmm you don't remember the
badass nanny very hired it was like I'm
from tiger King yeah
you don't know that hot-ass nanny that
the other dude hired chef Lowe's nanny
Jeff flows nanny oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know her a friend of mine knows her
no way What did he say not real really
was fate she's a bottle service girl she
never slept with him or nothing she's
not even a real nanny damn that's the
word on the street
how you gonna bottleservice me you can't
even bottle a baby you know what I'm
saying we drop a bottle it's all good if
you bombed up that baby yeah a lot of
problems then you end up like Gangnam
style yeah
well [__] haze ganging up so would
you consider him a one-hit wonder
no he's big in Korea look at how many
views is that Nick 3.5 billion is that
it how much can the counter go how hot
can they kind of know nine nine billion
nine million that [__] there's a song
that every physically mentally
emotionally people in wheelchairs takes
over the world people that are raised in
like a fishbowl yep you know you got my
permit yeah Murr everybody can dance too
there's some everybody horrible it's the
Macarena oh yeah this is the Japanese
Macarena bro
% Macarena Mexicans you can have that
this is Chinese what do we have I read
Korean wow I had no idea here's the
thing Korean needs to join another group
because y'all keep bugging they're gonna
be racing yeah dude
y'all need a Tokyo Drift into another
culture and merge which is one thing
only did y'all need a [__] kelabra
because everybody knows to a lot of this
Asian beef is hitting the streets these
days dude people all used to think oh
all Asian people here's how it went
people thought oh all Asian people are
Japanese and then people realize all
that's not true that's fake so then now
you start realizing they got Japanese
Chinese now Japanese Chinese Laotians
it's high wanna use creatine creatine
creatine ease yeah the creatine I've
heard that yeah there's no jack and
they're [__] dripping from their
elbow yeah
you know they got water in the meat but
everybody but they're good people good
people ro you people yeah and then now
people are starting realize that the
Chinese have beef with the Japanese and
the Koreans have beef with the [__]
in the North Olien North Koreans hate
South Korea yeah people are starting to
realize that there's a lot of disparity
in the Asian community Asian community
where people used to think you know
ignorant people and I've been ignorant
we used to think that oh there's just
Asian people you can remember what
Australia you know so many Asians
and I finally got good cuz I've got guys
there's like Chinese people and chicken
that wet their chin I couldn't believe
how many Asians were and I'm like yeah
there's a ton of Chinese people I heard
Jim Begg do they're Japanese yeah then
we'd go that's like dams a ton of
Japanese beer I'd like dude those are
Korean by then so I got it yeah but then
I what are these people what are these
people boom boom Japanese Chinese Korean
and how do you want Asian people in the
black community interact I've never
really been even gotten a read on that
our really Asian people dropped the
n-word though we've been over this a lot
of Asian rappers they'll drop the
n-words and songs and have a black dude
in the song with it yeah so
uncomfortable there's a popular asian
rapper who changed his name to Brian but
he originally came out as rich chigga
really mm chigga chigga chigga fair i'm
not matter rich to go there he is rich
Brian hey it's Brian rich chigga yeah
gang brah I think I remember him
actually RIS chigga I remember singing
to do with chicka and I thought that
that was pretty pretty ball too checked
out pretty I thought it was pretty brave
I thought I checked out you know some
videos yeah let's see it let's see one
of his out here oh here we go
I think says Tokyo Drift on it I'm not
I'm not trying to be funny I think it
does it does it does oh oh this is a
freestyle oh [__] he's my son
[Music]
but don't got the nerves Akashi pumping
popping on fire instrumentals I'm
playing I'm picking to play Coachella
my future depends on this [__] I'm
making the Miller you making mistakes
see you when you're back what I've been
in some cases are better that's what
you're saying my [__] listen
Seiko check spending on me like a
pancake and cancel them with a day god
like what did they go my mother rubbers
I don't wanna get his man so good but
you short like a ball
I thought he made the beat with the Cubs
oh that's interesting
that's cool she was fine [__] he's a
young man huh
that's a young strapping man in la borde
is [__] yeah that's pretty creative you
tiger released a quarantine song he did
yeah boys are just born the end the
studio and start dropping them in the
next day I mean that's just in his
apartment just doing visual [__] that's
a creative limitation people can do
anything though anything's kind of
allowed an Asian stuff is cool right as
long as you're good at it you can't do
anything half-ass as long as you're the
best at it it's fine you can do whatever
you better be damn good yeah you better
be damn math gymnastics but I mean my
keys balancing napkins on his neck you
guys are gonna break dancing yes the
best yes break dancers hold up better
than like the New York Street boys yes
the New York Street boys are Asian yeah
I'm sure they are
Oh Jabbawockeez they're all the are
agent a friend of mine has made one yeah
there are the best number ones are what
never Korean all these Koreans are
otherwise Red Bull breakdancing yeah man
you got to get out when you break dance
huh do you get that fat ass on the up
down the court do a couple of stuff you
ain't no Brad Williams huh yeah I'm
lookin [__] dance yeah but I could do
some of this [__] I could do that oh I
could do that I could do the kind of
breakdancer where you're like always
waiting for the guy to go on the ground
and do something he never does yeah me
too and I just does it all that was
awesome you don't get [__] break
dances for him yeah
like a [__] I think he was a
real break dancer with me really I think
so uh hope not it's a horrible [__]
career pretty sure yes there's no in
gaming
know how do you make money being a
cheerleader where does the cent where's
the yeah I guess you could be
Jabbawockeez but chances are not good
cheerleader yep you known him for a
while yeah you know I'm firm maybe yes
seven years I'm just flies yeah he's
always been so funny man God he's so
funny he's been doing stand-up since
he's I think he said it's like since
eighteen he started I think Portland
Seattle and you settle and but his
parents were like really strict and he
had to go to school he's like a
biologist or something he's wicked smart
yeah aviation yeah he worked for a
airing he worked for Boeing yeah yeah he
was building [__] bombs or whatever
planes but for the good side before the
good side yeah for the right side if IA
man war if you guys get to see this guy
live man it's [__] absolutely
ridiculous player yeah I come from his
own lane here's a he just dropped a well
just but about a month ago dropped a
special they didn't a commie Central
YouTube wow yeah that's a shot with a
belly room
I know it's just unfortunate to put
anything on Comedy Central YouTube well
you know that's true where he's able to
put it on himself to his flames really
really smart like I'm sure you put the
clips out smart no I'm not saying any
Connor and it is special but [__]
Comedy Central's is a [__] nightmare
he got rid of David Spade show like
that's the best show on there the best
quote I ever heard about Comedy Central
Amy Schumer told me one time she cuz if
you gave them a gold brick they would
bronze it I had a good pilot with him
brother who worked really hard on Harry
I'll vouch with you on this I saw deals
pilot and I was like dude this is gonna
be the biggest thing you've ever done
and they said nah so this is my chance
to say [__] y'all
I feel bad for we cantle reviews on here
than they get on the David Spade show
yeah I know but that speech shows for a
while but after years and years of you
know yeah yeah yeah I'm sounding like a
hater it's all good no you're not you
sound like a guy who gave him a good
opportunity they passed on it
yeah just took him a year just all the
jerking around and the slow [__] and
just yeah I guess it didn't make me kind
of mad well that's fine Jarek you along
the whole time yeah you know don't say
jerk dogs yeah sorry they just kind of
pull you along by your dicks everything
that Chin's about so [__] Ravi
they're about to rob a [__] target
for the cup of noodles not target for a
cup of noodles I know it's still same it
seems a lane a same Lane but different
same I feel like mine was better
yeah like mine was a little more radium
I've been a little more specific here's
a white guy that as a concern let's go
to this guy Oh what are we really doing
right down where happening the king in
ER stinging thank you guys for having me
here today man just want to say that
Knicks neck of the woods and I got it
King interesting for you guys letting
your girlfriend give you a haircut all
the barber shops are shut down right now
and I got to keep my grooming on point
so yeah I'm gonna let her give me a
mullet she has no type of haircutting
experience at all others to be able to
handle this before looks like I'll hit
you guys back with the final product
oh damn it [__] looking frosted she did
a great job
oh damn for a little cotton eyed Joe oh
[__] drinking a beverage at a fresca is
that is everything I think dudes great
good-looking young man chewed a great
JAMA haircut Nick doing anything you can
to squeeze Wisconsin
I stayed for two things ro cheese and
Steven Avery don't cheese Steven Avery
and Nick and what's that guy and who is
the big running back that played it was
calm Ronde they have a history of great
running well it but it's wrong it's
wrong so you definitely know try the new
guy the guys coming out this years a
[__] you almost won Heisman yeah you
know I'm talking about ya know what I'm
gonna get torn apart cuz I'm blanking
right now but I got a lot going on back
here but yeah you don't doctors me
what's everybody for name because Joe
Burrell won the [__] high pieces of
[__] nobody remembered some [__]
demon for trudging up there in the mud
playing [__] behind behind all giant
white boys for it I mean the Dallas
Cowboys was off at the line
John Taylor he's loaded up and I want to
say he did look it up and [__] would
vouch for it if we could get any ideas
it's hot enough to know sometimes about
Asian people or thinking or feeling and
then you cover up 60% of your [__]
visual territory this of course was a
draft ideas from top go I can't tell
what's going on with Jim in how my class
are getting fogged up to know if you're
gonna die you [__] go back into the
database dude you gotta tighten up no
bro I'm sitting over here with marge
schott she looks like the shittiest
Mortal Kombat character yet
[Laughter]
marge schott side these are here [__]
Crisco Sabo over here machine guard of
the [__] episode man dude my hilarious
go check him out if you get a change
what's your special on Comedy Central
comes restful Comedy Central's YouTube
page yeah I will watch it on his
Facebook when he puts the clips out
there man well he's I put him out but he
needs the views yeah gang keen you're
saying lady girlfriend caught you here
yeah be careful though because all these
[__] who give you that [__] simple
Jack mullet man you know you got to be
careful I want let my girl touch my hair
really mullets are looking pretty dope
dude you got everyone doing mow it's now
man well I'll say this man I know that
little Cape down the back though it's
getting a little long man let's come in
now what are you gonna do with it though
this race I get to I know I don't know
what to do I'm not gonna let it go long
I don't know what to do what do you mean
then you've already said you already yo
you're not gonna let it go I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna keep growing it like I'm a
foot in a rock band bro that [__] dude
you said Clay Matthews huh really I
don't know what to do
get that [__] decide what's this
quarantine is over I'm gonna switch it
up well you could thin it I think just
keeping the top don't let the top get
too long and let that back go long man
what's your son and never see you with a
[__] long hair you're right
you don't know something like oh my dad
looks like a [__] lesbian all the
time
winter sunny be like I have some pride
in my father look at his [__]
beautiful hair yeah you're right
when you're right you're right yeah look
at you right there doing you step
here cowboy is he's soaking wet he
leakin that's our [__] boy right there
that is our boy this is Brendan on the
DL brah this is this is me if I ever got
my [__] together
the boys so jacked I wish I had another
50 yeah yeah well get him holding those
dumbbells there you go dude look at that
dick room bro oh look at Gold's Gym dick
roots I'll tell you this though too as
good-looking as he is he's also like a
legit trainer training for doom like
he's a legit trainer he trained her for
doom for days overdue Murray for doom
Larry Bird oom I don't know great name I
don't know this kid I went to school
with named Larry Verdun no he didn't
yeah he trained up he was the youngest
person in our community ever to get
scabies and that's the senior citizen
disease we looked at up next gay bees
and he beat it uh I still fighting I
would say they're definitely in overtime
he's in the 12th round he's at for a
long time to do it but yeah look at that
uh-uh oh yeah Oh scabies a little bug
dude I got a [__] uh I'm a tick on me
from mountain biker man really think I
going straight to my nutsack
what do you know what kind of bike and
you doing he would eat mountain biking
really yeah come iets go look what I
posted man I mean I'm out there bro you
should get a bike and go with me what
I'm so lonely I mean all of them
mountain biking yeah it's right behind
my house dude you're gonna end up in
full-contact chest before this is all
over I feel like that'd be cool Wow look
at this man that's right by home behind
my house dude specialized hitter there
and we shallows on right did you unhook
the peloton or is that Wow
like a real bike full go dude that [__]
is a work out what's that [__] in your
mouth
that's a gel pack go you will man that's
how you that's I get up that goddamn
mountain that's what else you got Nick
yeah let's get into something here huh
what
guy yeah you got to get I think you have
to go full on the cup man you got to get
a good cut it's a good time to maybe we
should let fans vote on what kinda I
should do dang look at Brandon yeah I
started GoFundMe there's a hundred
thousand dollars for you rip your dick
off some tits and give you a rump like
co-op and you got a split so it's only
fifty thousand for you and fifty for me
I you just get the sex a nose job will
kill you either
what does young fellow one there's
nothing nose piercing and let's see what
this beautiful young lady wants hipster
thirst wrap this little Bjork fan wants
right here trend black fishing yes it's
where you dye your skin like it's
opposite of Sammy Sosa so you know Sammy
Sosa want to get really white it's when
like white people races try to look more
black yeah I didn't know that was a
thing so like I baby did it uh bad I'll
bring up her Instagram a second
in the past people have said ariana
grande has tried it it's just like a
bunch of tan and people can't tell kylie
jenner's they think it's racial
profiling like they think it's a little
bit of ultra uh yeah the appropriation
get the [__] down
people can't be tan now okay i can't get
tan for girls it's usually like the tan
the lip filler yes yep sign me up hey is
she of age or no she's still 17 let's
pretend she's 18 that binge is bad she's
is 18 he's twenty two or three maybe no
dude you didn't redo a music video with
her still how did you engage with her at
all no she was a child
engage like was there any interaction
when you asked if the child in an adult
and oh hey hey you want to have a seat
child I wanna have a seat which is funny
because of what Theo played in this
video yeah he's a creep I have played a
PDF file in defeat you and delitos get
casted as PDF files yeah dude I did I'll
tell you one funny thing to happen on
this video said I don't have the video
but it's good music man huh
her music ain't bad well here's what
happened David Spade hit me up and said
hey you should do this music video with
bad baby right and so I was like oh man
well obviously you know I want to
impress David Spade this does and she
had just put one out that he was in that
was really good so if you look up that
one he was like a milkman and it was
really dope and I was like all this
seems you'd be something funny in it I
thought it's gonna be cool yeah so then
I get there and they said y'all we use a
pedophile and I said nah man that's this
is a rumor that your character yeah and
they said that's your character boy you
got all defensive you got no proof yeah
the character those videos a fake man
well no no what so this was hers oh this
is her as a low yachty no yah-tchi
[Music]
she's doing though yeah this video is
great
so then anyway I ended up being a
pedophile and a difference yours was a
little creepy like you're funny it was
more creepy there was one funny outtake
where I called her a wig or during one
of the takes I should get mad huh did
she get me know if she died laughing and
and it was a hot to find the video I had
the video somewhere can't even put it in
the video can you release the outtakes
or no you can't rubber I can't what are
they gonna do kill you boy Here I am
behind the scenes being a PDF file right
there god damn that is a pity of off
I've ever seen and that's me also my
thang that I'm making a
behind-the-scenes video in a bathroom
but uh but anyway yeah so that was the
deal but yeah there was one great moment
right oh this is it it was during this
scene and we're the wigger joke come in
at it do it it was just there like okay
just make fun of her for like thirty
seven you're like you little weirder and
I was like you [__] way we don't need
that we don't need that energy here the
whole set died uh she died - it's right
by the funnest time the funniest moment
on it but I saw her once at CAA with
security guard so she is white I was
hoping she would say what's up but just
a security guard she was white I mean
she's transitioning now how do you feel
about that I mean I think she's just she
just looks tan how did she was black I
don't know they show me the black she
has some bangers them Liat they'll yeah
I'm just playing a [__] pervert you
look great though as bella thorne right
yeah
ty dolla sign - was he on set with you
no the only person 45 million views son
people hate on this girl man I celebrate
her going from dr. Phil to this shukru
widening boomin you got to see the
behind the scenes definitely her mom was
there like running the show she had like
a whole team you know just a different
universe different universe but for her
though yeah she was pretty nice no he
was exactly like she is on these things
up in that little world you know just
wise I Jung like gangster like money in
the bank now like rapper it's like yeah
like every girl that's not her [__]
is just talking [__] outside of a
carwash somebody somewhere in Tucson
right now that was the vibe like if
you're not her but of your you were like
basically just talking [__] outside of a
car washing Tucson yeah like all the
girls to see out like a [__] hot
topic no but she made it yeah this is
like a skill like thought topic
basically wigger topic which is yeah did
not define that video though it's pretty
[__] funny you should post it oh I'm
so excited bro when I did it
Oh music views are the [__] I love that
you're in that one no I was excited
about yelled wygor at her
that's so funny I wish I would have kept
that yours is great Delia's is fantastic
with a [__] logic and mmm great Oh
[__] Chris Nate yeah black fishing
are they you see you guys seen a lot of
that in the black culture
I've never seen I've never what does it
upset you I don't know what she looks
like well that one she was white now
she's mad she's just real look at her
yeah I mean it's the girl from the video
and then that's her that's her oh here's
my thing if that's what she wants to do
who gives a flying [__] is she using the
n-word no right she's acting you know
that's what she surround ourselves with
you know if you really looked black she
looks good I'm assuming she's 18 you
said 22 she's not she's definitely of
age now man she was a 16 when she was on
are you sure 17 right now as I confirm I
looked it up this morning I don't to get
in trouble
either she's a good-looking human being
on the show she needs to put on some
clothes an actor age yeah this is
unbelievable man
it's out of control hey please get me
out of here but what about people look
in asian people that are crossing over
you know people that are is it the how
many white guys got their eyes done to
look Asian
yeah Asian to get their eyes done to
look white yeah a lot of I feel like
more girls are doing they're like
Melania Trump thing where it's just like
the facelift makes you look a little
more you know you don't have to do that
with a lot of girls are doing Kenneth
round eyes because yeah pedophile what
do you got - now you an Asian file no
that's eyes are already Asian huh what I
mean
cat has eyes from her own body and head
and Bri Jen where she though she was
born in America weren't you yeah see all
right well you know I'm saying where
your parents were born [__] out of your
neck Jesus
let's do another Jesus Christ what's up
- yo what's up Brandon GE Z's really hit
rock bottom
disc golf do you King it do you sing it
because I mean I come out here at 8
o'clock in the morning drink a couple
tall boys smoke a couple joints gang
[__] that sounds fun gang gang
buzz buzz oh [__] yeah get that buzz
disc get that buzz dis buzz lightyear
diff dog [__] buzz baldwin dude out
there he hit that karl malone [__]
post up see that Sean disc off have you
played it I've never played it that
sounds fun as hell no you can't go on
the golf courses right now though right
and do they just go on like regular golf
course and throat disc no there's like
an actual course for ya oh it's that big
yeah I've done it man idea I'm gonna get
more hip if you go to in like Colorado
they have like really well groomed ones
that have actual greens and like lakes
and stuff it's it gets pretty serious
this one's from dude I need to check it
out look at look at a map like oh yeah
it's never played have you guys I just
made my first skate video the other day
you put on Instagram yeah bring that
[__] up I'm not lying
did you have music claim like all those
small things and [__] do it ollie
cuz I'm obliquity to fit okay Jeff's
Park is my boy let's see this can't hear
it yep
aloud now that music is intense that's
intense music on it's very fun to skate
to though right if you sounds like white
supremacist music no huh
are they is that not the track from
[__] American History X oh you can
skate skate
oh damn son
that wasn't an ollie yeah yeah we did
it's exactly what we thought yeah we
thought you're full of [__] back over
that resume there are some [__] red
flags in that now we know it's so cool
with black mission yeah go back over
that risk
look at my racism charge you're a liar
you're an outlier man [__] culture
vulture of endeavor
save some for the rest the white kids
get your big ass to Cheerilee yeah man
when does it stop no he's only guitar
[Laughter]
I posted guitar video 9 man Kevin we
talking about God what's this [__]
duck dynasty do talking about what's up
Brendan what's up vo coming to you from
Key West Florida we've got a king under
sting it for you fresh coconuts
[Laughter]
Danette these got that power so do you
know more people die from coconuts
falling on them than they do shark
attacks huh no I do that's something you
read my [__] up
toilet books that's what bad baby told
me I got it from her Instagram what I
love Cogan's you're my mom you want my
mom to buy me a real coconut would like
the hair all over it you know like the
real [__] coconut from the store and
they give me a butter knife hey have fun
dude it took me hours to get that
[__]
our it's kept me busy though I mean the
basement just [__] do it take me
hours damn really no that's my fake
you're easy man yeah kind of [__] up
and I think about it yeah it sounds it
sounds [__] illegal
first of all these people are stealing
obviously some rich versus you notice
look stealing fruit from people I'm all
about it oh it's called death by coconut
man I thought this was a dessert it
sounds like that sounds like a cool band
yeah you can have that yeah he wants his
girlfriend to cut his beard oh you know
we're talking about anymore dude well
obviously on the last episode before he
gets shut down
you guys like coconuts huh I do idea
seems like kid I love them I love
coconut water I like the meat I like
nuts you break them open they smell like
ladies lying in the Sun I don't know
that huh what's that from it's made it
up okay
no it's from Marley thing you know this
asian I'm trying to remember this asian
guy used to always sing it to me I'm not
cool
after giving massage huh after massage
you break them open this man like late
there's a line in that song I think it
might've been a black guy actually a lot
coconut you break them open any line I
don't know this song oh it's a
widespread panic is what it is and
here's a brother right here or some
[__] white guy trying to be black who
is this this is on to a relationship
advice Oh Chris light brown now this guy
is mixed well yeah he's a good skin tone
this guy has that skin tone oh that's
with it man
don't mess with it do not do it don't
[__] with the paint job caramel what do
you got Brian coming at you from
Jacksonville Florida
aka waxen Ville gang [__] dude buddies
me and my wife we're expecting a baby
September 3rd super excited about it but
the hormones are through the roof know
when you got a thought you like cries
about everything or she's like super
happy with my wife some things or she's
like angry at me for nothing I try to
blow her off but it's like it's insane
how do you deal with the emotions I know
this was more for Brendan because he's
probably only one with kids there
- awesome babies huh what do you do I
try to blow her off what else can I do
we got about five more months or six
more months left you're in the thick of
it son hope your boy out
bang-bang bless nuts gang [__] bro dude
I tell you what here's the other thing
girls are blame it on the pregnancy some
girl might just be an [__] really
yeah Wow yeah my listen I don't the only
advice out for you I just booked [__]
city tours I just booked tours I was on
the road to every [__] week for nine
months nine month or so she got pregnant
see ya she was mean really oh yeah me
what'd she do she eat flaming hot
cheetos and rub her fingers of my eyes
and [__] Oh
yeah they're [__] [__] man good
luck bro den ain't that bad you pick up
a hot dude pick up a hobby like mountain
biking must be gone for hours
yeah but what if you want to take a
chance of the rattlesnakes cuz they're
nice What did he say he said he said she
does she's what see it's like it's hot
and cold man like that they're just
because the their body creates more home
hormones because the baby and they have
all that hormones going through them so
they just flap the handles over any long
breaks my heart man
it's crazy and what happens to the baby
you know nine months comes out he's cool
[__] it's crazy awesome cool comes out
all that [__] nightmare to make
diamonds gotta go through a little
pressure and that's true gang [__] good
luck brother
good luck out Bobby man pick up a hobby
yes stay in your car do postmates do
become an uber driver yeah you don't
need the money just do it uber drivers
risky though postman you can leave this
[__] out there on the curb you know you
could leave it yeah true bloopers
probably taking a hit right now right
nobody trying to get those ubers always
a little Hubert don't you how is it what
is this is a-booming well I don't think
it's a boomin I only do this do you find
that it's quicker to get overs now or
not at the same time it's pretty point
it is yeah I'm sorry birds like eight
months I had no car terrible idea um but
I thought you were driving Nupur damn
bro I thought that's what Theo said I
never said anything like that I've been
sitting here when I said something like
that man
because you said you you BER huh you
said you said to him you over wine oh he
oh you're here word here oh just use
uber I thought maybe you're just doing
Ober as a side gig Rob wish I knew how
to fight yeah well I wish I do not a
skateboard ships passing in the night
bro
[__] barely Larkin over here let's
get this thing going dude if we started
yeah yeah
ooh yoky Oh Brendan debate club my
lights remember the time yeah he does
man or any jujitsu gym still open right
now or no nope Wow Kim that's crazy
the pros are still getting the work in
but like the classes and the kit you
can't do it dude I saw a black guy in
the park by my apartment yesterday
trying to fly a kite and it was a
[__] was there any wind I don't know
if there's a winner or not but it was
the most I don't think there was and it
was the most [__] weirdest thing I've
ever seen in my life depressing right
yeah just forever seemed like an
erectile dysfunction video like one of
the hoes get you down it was just like
it would go like 12 feet or eight feet
is just [__] crash is unbelievable man
but it's different times brah especially
those black dudes flying kites bro
that's when you know the [__] this is
the end
Chappelle come have some [__] respect
dawg you think our [__] role dog
right here [__] with kite son you don't
know you don't know you're me neither
it's hired on the spot what is this guy
YZ what is Remember the Titans or Friday
Night Lights better miss Denise but and
I'm 11 let's start in the culture corner
I know where you guys has everybody seen
both shows I've never seen Friday Night
Lights I've seen the movie not the show
and red wine understand me either you
even see the show mm-hmm you haven't
seen it you've seen it it was on CW yeah
well you never seen Friday Night Lights
movie go watch fine it broke during this
thing you're thinking about what do i
watch i watch ozarks a [__] piece of
[__] always works the same episode over
and over again don't ruin it for me
huh I just started season - you'll be
fine yeah it's the same yes they're
trying to hustle laundry money for the
cartel yeah it never ends
it's [__] the show is so exhausting
exhausting
it's like we did it and they're like
good job now 50 billion yeah [__] dude
it's basically 30 episodes trying to
decide if the sister is hot or not
that's what I feel like oh yeah yeah is
she of age huh she of age yeah she just
have that one sex scene in the boat he
does season one oh I think wife's a
little [__] [__] though and she what
mean yeah you know so I like fry that
lights though bro remember the times
Remember the Titans yeah I remember it
hayden Panettiere he's a little girl in
it brother she knows defense and [__]
mmm I was like Nick Saban
remember the back of my dick dude short
side left side Oh
Friday Night Lights is the best for me
it goes Breaking Bad fighting out lights
what do you have in it I haven't seen I
know chin hasn't seen it Nick you've
only seen Remember the Titans yeah I've
seen a movie Friday Night Lights and I
read the book back in the day when I
worked at the library in high school but
throw that in there wait way to dry my
erection up bring the show to screeching
hi you still books in [__] I just read
magazines and newspapers dude our
library still booming not really right
could you just reach it whenever you
want you just read stuff online or get
the book online library what I think you
bring up a good point yeah like why
would anybody go to a library now first
of all I'm not gonna listen to you ever
discuss with oh that's crazier than
[__] since the guy with the Rugrats
[__] hoodie on right now
sweet hoodie bad baby this is what a one
row
yeah you [__] right in there who else
you got Nick that doesn't even drive
over yeah man nobody I put it was good
man that [__] was shut out here later
what's her name
Jules oh yeah what's her last name is
Jules fan mm-hmm yeah
have you met her family uh yeah yeah her
dad cut my hair sometimes that's like a
dowry speak much English I just showed
him a picture
oh this like 90 day fiancé this is she's
she's born and raised Oh see so she's
she knows whatever like nine day fiancé
grow in some cultures that's what you
get you marry the daughter you get a
haircut
I'll take did a good job hey you did a
good job huh checking the water brother
dude
[__] art is on here if he doesn't honor
his parents he cuts his own throat slit
your wrists you bro I just had a vision
the cops come in like two months or now
and we're all dead in here once yeah we
can't [__]
you talking entire episode but one thing
I don't like about the mass is you smell
your own breath all day yeah you shits
fire i finally learning huh oh it's so
bad I'm like Jesus disgust yeah breath
can be pretty funky
woody what else you guys hearing that
the virus is gonna end soon anybody got
any Intel well baseball's coming back in
June basketball is gonna come back it is
the other made a deal they're gonna do
in the Arizona all teams are gonna play
that really god damn dude yeah would eat
your [__] news from Nick these guys
before the show about the MLB come oh
yeah that's why we're the bat the
baseball jersey man I'm [__] crunk for
it perfect is Arizona's just human I
mean they shut things down but they're
fine they made golfing an essential yeah
Wow you're saying the disease can't live
there why because of the heat right
meanwhile our [__] governor wants to
shut down til [__] June yeah next June
[__] guy
that guy brah beat his ass what's his
name
gavin newsom gavin newsom these play for
the Toronto Blue Jays that guy oh my god
the governor now no I don't think so
that's Ozzie Newsome yeah oh I hate it
when you have one guy that's good and
you get a different person with the same
name like you know you know that kind of
[__] confusing yeah shout the baseball
shut the UFC leading the way though
they're the first ones to do it
April 18th somebody else'll fall man
shout out the baseball some real haters
out there shout out
I don't know Joe Musgrove baseball fan
why baseball pitcher watches this show
Walker Buehler pitcher
shut up to yellow wolf he watches the
show does he I think I could see him
watching it shout out to Tony Hawk
[Laughter]
shoutout to Hawk from NWS old wrestlers
shut up to a Jayhawk
ohhow State linebacker dreamed a great
captain
shout out to chop to hawk the guy from
gigolos on Showtime
oh really you know that's you know
shout-out to uh mmm cat you want to
shout anybody out shout out to rich
chicka oh we end on Gangnam style I keep
wanting to hear that [__] song and
Gangnam style
shake I started this all off rich [__]
doing the damn thing got bling denim
style he had one more hit though to AB
real banger after this oh [__] look at
him dude don't let anybody tell you
can't do anything look at this [__]
guy oh wow look at unbelievable dude and
this guy's homosexual or not but the bet
on it he is good look at that little kid
that's advanced I will say this he did
make this a thing yeah yeah
anybody yeah but he did it's universal
now it is yeah yeah if you see somebody
do that you know they're gonna [__] a
gang of up well there's nothing more
[__] beautiful than a [__] fat
asian creating a nice towel and a steam
room some relaxing about it look at this
[__] yeah bro we got to get this guy on
the podcast there we do I think he
passed away
I don't really know Mike I think you did
right doing it he's touring well we play
just song seven times in a row just an
Asian girl with no ass or Japanese women
not a lot of cheek in that Japanese
areas do if you got an ass as an Asian
women discarded who is that Ellen hey
that's the old Brendan hell yeah that's
me in the cool car
[Music]
that's great hey here's one more hit
though Nick
he has another hit does he yeah a real
big kid he has one more that was a it
[__] slap I think in the song with
Snoop Dogg do that so it might be true
gentlemen I forget it was big though oh
look at that one halfs out - there's a
dark want impersonation right now there
it is 1.3 billion views Wow
you see it and I think you're right who
else did somebody in it this way
followed up with Gangnam style with this
[__] how old is he
47 this one's in Asian the song we're
saying how you think
so if he's in a fashion area that be
Japan right his rhetoric will shut this
one off the song sucks [__] small copy
man 1.3 bill yeah shut up this young
inside they're really starting it
they're starting to do all teams are
gonna be out there playing the Arizona
no crowd and then and then football
starting just they're gonna be regular
season camp everything in Arizona
no everywhere everywhere well that's
crazy then why is that crazy why did
they get to do everywhere but then base
Boston because their season and start to
August OS you were saying Arizona
Arizona but yeah the other places don't
so would it they can't do it they will
they'll figure it out you don't know it
you don't know [__]
you don't know [__] dude all right
checks out bro I think that's it that's
it manic thanks for the banana pie yeah
shut up weird uh player is that is that
a specific player playing just red gang
[__] rush celebrating the whole league
right now really you know got a respite
I'm offering my Clevenger's got traded
to uh Cincinnati Reds really yeah he's a
people he was a pitcher for Cleveland
shut up to Mike yeah I'm just joking he
didn't but as if he's listening to this
he hears that these things that he did
funny be just rated now well you can
tell we don't want to leave but we have
to just give me the last episode man
might get shut down yeah if people know
that we're meeting like this I mean some
people do things everyone knows I don't
think anybody cares have we had anybody
that said shut it down I haven't no yeah
no yes maybe some bitch-ass fans and
chintz family I'm wearing this so people
know we're being careful I like that
yeah I'll wait chins [__] face right
now we go [__] dot Rona
do you remember when Steve Rannazzisi
died in 9/11 do so look man if that
can't stop us bro Roenick ain't [__]
stop I didn't stop Steve we got to do
something better than that
man we got to fake her own death we got
him we could do it you do it you can
have to hide though bro
that's tough I know you gonna have to
time out faking deaths right now
yeah this is what it's like man let's
motor you wanna be [__] white
Chappelle this is what it's like bro
just boring [__] conversation yep
how can we die you know how we go you
[__] die whenever ro you know
whatever white people get creative we
got a job I wrote ozark we have to die
of old age don't die out there y'all
yeah you guys stay alive man if it's the
last thing you do kick groaning the nuts
we're out yeah Brennan and Theo fighter
and wait I gotta go in and go hard in
the paint I do not think I am in Flo
black rifle coffee I'm ready to go I
need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts Flo is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are Instagram famous
damn
fresh off keto see a red like Andrew
Santino right every something hit like
the great Bambino gonna take the case so
indicate Cerritos but everything's gonna
be fine hate on me I do not mind looking
like the type of dudes I got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try to couldn't beat him quit playin
like Nintendo DS you don't want the
smoke like Joey Diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and I'm telling
incredible bread and Sun him me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up a sting
and the sting bee sting Rat King
Anna stinking enough steam Godspeed
trap got that cheese on a string
and the sting King in the stinking in
the sting bee sting rat King King in a
sting
and then sting got that cheese on the
stream Brendan and do fighter in Creole
shout out New Orleans and shout out to
Co Colorado more specifically Boulder
Brendan came in with a chip on his
shoulder but is still gold and yet is
still fire if you don't like King
Aniston you're a liar Brenda's got like
a thousand different hustles one of
them's that Nordstrom Rack to win tie
yours black rifle coffee we hear you
loud and clear your son on the email
like please get me out of here is way
too loud in here watching the Irishman
eating pizza drinking half a beer now
under Theo von looking like the tepid do
the trans Arita songs smoking cigarettes
with a snapback on let's a hit the [__]
and turn snapchat on it's all good we
still mess with you 18:11 Pico Boulevard
Oh get ahead Derek and Kat y'all doing
great Thursday upload not a minute late
y'all wanted to rap ahead a demonstrate
brand new studio y'all feelin great
putting Chris Delano in this place now
let's go and get you a game a sting
and the sting bee sting crack
and there's stinko a king and then stay
in a truck got the cheese on a string
the sting King in the sting King is a
sting bee sting Rat King
in a sting a king and a distinct kind of
bees and attract got that cheese on a
strong
[Music]